before we go a Texas Woman's simple note
of appreciation had a profound effect on
an Odessa police officer corporal Gary
Potter said he found the handwritten
words along with flowers on his police
vehicle on Monday the note said I do not
know you and you do not know me but I
thank you for your sacrifice
Potter said it meant so much because he
was going back to work for the first
time since a gunman shooting rampage in
Odessa and Midland over the weekend his
own family had to had come close to that
gun fire yesterday Potter met the woman
who wrote the note Bria
Montez I wish I could give so much more
and I was like I just want to show that
I personally am so thankful you gave
plenty believe me do a lot of people and
it turns out Montez is a nurse at a
Medical Center where some of the
shooting victims are now recovered never
underestimate the power of just writing
a note I leave him for my wife in the
morning sometimes a police car and it
works for a spouse it's a great thing
right that does it for us be sure to
tune in the CBS Evening News with Norah
O'Donnell tonight she'll continue
coverage of hurricane durian see
tomorrow here on CBS this morning
bye-bye